[Music]
I wrote my first song and my uncle
Brent's like Collision Center in a
really small town
and that song never coming home became
an overnight success
literally so I was just like yeah I'm
gonna
cause my name is Bailey's Everman this
is my new single never coming home never
did I intend this to happen we just got
a million streams on Apple music let's
go
so I quit my job and I was like dude I'm
just gonna like try music I'm gonna try
to do this
so you're going through the stage right
now where everything is like a pinch me
moment between a rock and a hard place
three of your songs then you're like
using
tips of the world make it into the top
ten exactly right isn't it crazy right
I ain't done this before so yeah I don't
know what's going on but I feel like the
music we're writing is like helping
people
are you comfortable with this title of
breakup Anthem King well I have like an
idea to write a song it's like yo in
this moment I feel like I could have
used a song that said this but I didn't
have that song so I'm gonna write this
song because
I think I could have used that back then
or wherever I needed it so this is where
it ends